it's time for the long came from
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
brought to you every monday wednesday
and project
presentation of them on jane what
wal-mart's company
maker are launching the world's most on
a block
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world
ahmed lawn jane
good evening this is frank not
now introduce our color that is for this
edition of the lawn gene costco
marisa from the c_b_s_ television news
staff
and francis w carpenter of the
associated press
our distinguished guest for this evening
mister presley's spender ambassador from
australia after the united states
but there was a pleasure to welcome back
an old friend
my guest tonight is only an old friend
of the costco program he's a tried and
true friend of our country
whatever the where trouble
diplomatically speaking
you can always count on our friend from
australia to pitch in when the going
gets rough
depression i guess give something
about the recent conference in manila
do we actually get what we wanted out of
that
southeast asian packed
depend upon what you mean oh...
what you wanted
i think that there was a are very
substantial meetings of meeting of minds
and having to go out to the difficulties
which were confronted with
i think was a very successful result
well it is to be any good actually have
india and the others
some of the southeast asian nation stay
out of the we certainly we wouldn't
anticipate because if we hadn't thought
it was good
you must make a stop somewhere we know
that other countries that have different
views to our own
uh... we understand the reasons why the
defense
about davis failures you know that we
should go ahead and we did go ahead
what do you think the uh... the comedy
threat in southeast asia is the next big
threat to that wearing their necks
the pitches to come from moscow
high i can say with any uh... any degree
of certainty whether mixed up usually
apply run everybody well it's always
applied where the weaknesses
my feeling is that has been the sometime
tossed that uh...
uh... trouble who always aka in that
part of the world if any further trouble
dot to ca
closer pursue a lot of people over this
country
correctly or incorrectly that the united
states is again holding me back if i may
say so on the south east asian defense
alliance and that we are committed to
fight in defense of certain countries
but uh...
they are not committed to fight unless
they find that the action is in their
self-interest bertram item if you look
taller
solicitor
uh... after all the under the terms of
the treaty
we'd all enjoy into exactly the same
obligation
uh... then you'd agree at all that
obligation in terms of betty because
bodies with countries depending upon
their military strength in economics
tend to end their interest
after all it is quite clear that uh...
that this country with a it's a greater
economic and military strength to
america to carry vegan major portions of
the movement eighteen piece in there
in that part of the world
but you will not find our own country
and lacking in his desire to work at all
times and carrying out to the folded
obligations we've got a big deal
support
i suppose all we're talking about
buchanan's venues and threats
what is the situation with
the communist party him your own
australia
well i suppose that's precisely the same
as it is in most democratic countries
for has been a communist party in our
country
there have been more mannequins to to
deal with it by legislation
uh... but the most effective means which
so far been found to deal with it
off first by uh... the record unionist
themselves inside a union
and secondly by what date is cold out
country the secret ballot for
reconnection of union leaders
and so that uh... we have a secret
ballot applies
communist leaders were not able to
engage in a usual tactics
of reading about
i think you've got a lot of applause for
america by the family that yoga morale
at that focused on an issue letter
yes they did an article of communism
have the russians reacted at all to
europe very stern action in connection
with this man but i am sanctuary we only
have been the result is well-known to
the world if i'm able to speak about
namely that uh... they withdrew their
raft they withdrew their embassy of
represent which in the spirit of and
uh... we as a result did likewise
they have no relations with the uh...
soviet union and i understand i
understand the inspector economic entry
gretna protocol correctly
relations among broken off
but uh...
when mister nixon
had come to his guns loaded priscilla
presley what about the situation in
japan now now the russians are trying to
draw japan into that paid over would you
consider that a dangerous situation for
your country and for
i do not don't worry about that uh...
jian
prime aim arbor russian in relation to
japan
is at least utilization of japan
but open about that
it's purpose is to seek
by whatever means are are open to it
by blemish goodbye pressured by in by
name by internal operations
tourette bring japan into the orbit of
the soviet uh... and communist influence
afterall stalin's sent uh... a long time
ago that uh...
effect that could be accomplished in the
belief of the soviet was at that
that for the world of the communist
world would be invincible
and so uh... that any attempt to advise
my rational by the communists
a protective ten into uh... into its
orbit
uh... is one which is grocers concern
with roster to all the free world whose
purpose of ought to be to do whatever it
can
uh... to enable that japan to develop
and be mankind as a democratic country
will suffer c_e_o_s
does australia fear most the spread of
communism or is it afraid of every
vilified aggression by japan
not at all times that we have been that
have been twenty-odd accepting the
proposition that the roots of democracy
have gone down deep into the uh...
japanese wildlife
it's uh... very proper observations to
make let me see the immediate problem in
the foreseeable future
aspect of communist aggression
what do you think about the rearmament
germany is at boeing australians where
much of a new tears because uh...
afterall into world war was a we have
heard that we have come into it
into a state of war means that after
seven seas
as a result of incident which took place
a long way from atul in europe
and so what it takes place in europe is
a consequence to us
we believe in very firmly
but you cannot deal with segment of the
world except in terms of
seen the whole problem globally
gossipers ilike to it
turn to a place is a little near to your
uh...
country then uh... you know that's korea
r_u_ withdrawing your troops in korea
the way the
we have in the british have at least a
portion of that there have been already
it was not only in the last
to three days and these nuns were all
discussed a cross between a the
different nations
and that we have the same as you will
withdraw on some of our troops do you
think that will create a vacuum that
looked at the commerce to try to come
back down again i don't think so if you
think they'll observed armistice i do
not think the president and missus my
own judgment i do not think we are
likely to meet
in career foreseeable future
immediate resumption october depression
the first year garcia sitting at the
share of australia that coming up
general assembly of the united nations
opening next week
and this letter industry questions there
and
one that every one of the united states
is interested in is the admission of red
china do you think it's going to give us
trouble at this coming session i don't
think any more than in the past
what do you think will happen to it
postponed again
uh...
i would think that uh... there wasn't
any uh...
a real danger of communist china being
the president of the nations at this
issue
series and the foreseeable future is out
of phrases banded about i think
well to look at the court said it's a
his band around like so many other
places but none of us can see anymore
than that
a certain a certain that
top of the future
and that there is nothing in at the time
of the in life in this paper that is it
what is the president about their
suppresses the
desire out greece to incorporate cypress
with his empire out past you are all the
davidians going to back the
position of great britain
and his reluctance to turn over the
island of cyprus to decrease
uh... i will do no more than say that
uh... this is a process and other
privately which great britain is
interested
but we do have event this uh... for many
other reasons and from private popping
out buddy close association with great
britain
well you've got another case is close to
home you've got the indonesians wanting
to take over
west new d_n_a_ mansion
and what it is on that without the use
of the next best more months
we say in the first place it doesn't
matter which is uh... one which ought to
be brought into the night of nations
uh...
at all
and secondly when the uh... if she was
examined this in the slightest merit in
mclean of indonesia
that they're making
meet these people of west new guinea off
quite different people altogether
i've never from eye-popping able to
understand
i walked justification of a tropical
otherwise
you can hand over that
i think that either by this or that
means
uh... one-and-a-half million people a
lot different people altogether
without asking them what they think we
don't have all the people these days i
have to anyone
the president has said in this country
britain exercise a veto over the actions
of the united states and in turn india
exercise a veto over the actions of
uh... accurate would you say that uh...
areas
well from my mister cochran's trade
deficit
that's uh... slogan which has been about
a big deal yet
uh...
it's quite clear that uh... his never
nationwide if it wants to act
at the seal a cost of combat
that which it is too in respective
eleven nations think
inflicted by any veto
nation if it wants to come so he will do
this irrespective of the people think
but in these days
in the world in which we live
uh... it's a very wise policy to have to
go out to the views about the nation's
to condition
precisely what the policy of the nation
should be
about to have a doctorate determine
policy and it's quite impossible for the
clinton policy
without having the gop you've a lot of
people of the world
suppressing out the present time rows of
proposal for peacetime atomic who seems
to be coming along right uh...
australia's element in that yes we
indicated are acceptance are believed to
have a proposal rock beginning
suffers it's almost a year since you've
been on this program
i to ask you to feel that the alliance
of a free nations is as strong as it was
during the korean war or other scenes
showing just a little yet
right around the office of the so that
they were in the last twelve months so
that has been a substantial shift in the
balance of power throughout the world
behind uh... united nations of course
the struggle for power goes on
that probably because of the addressee
address that policy of the soviet russia
and uh... and the communist china
and uh... that uh...
changing that balance of power as prime
we do it
uh... to the success of the promise of
hepatic commuting indochina
and of the psychological successes
example in preventing thereby well
bringing about that
indirectly head of the collapse of the
d_c_
and by the progress which they have made
a note on the competitive with them
i mean in the result of course if they
i'd change in the balance of i don't
mean by that that they have the best way
to keep the balance of power but they
have to change it
and their program the set
we had a problem which confronts of the
free world greater urgency
thank you very much success is always a
pleasure to have something to say that
it hit
competitive
the opinions expressed on the mounting
problems cope with those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching prosto laws larry lissa
and francis w carpenter
our distinguished guests was surfers
december ambassador from australia to
the united states
theater show watch for the world
heavyweight boxing championship between
rocky marciano and as a charles is
launching the world's most haunted watch
in the world of support the fact is that
launching watches artificial for tommy
world championships in all sports
encompass associations the world over
including the contest board of the
american automobile association the
national aeronautical association the
american power boat association and many
many others
analyze this so
the answer is no one seems great
accuracy and completeness and ability
the fact is that in some seventy five
years of accuracy competitions at
government observatories launching
watches have consistently maintained a
place of honor
established many records one compass
prizes and awards
these are but some of the reasons why
launching his deservedly known as the
world's most only watch
the watch of higher spruce trees
among the finest waters of the world
and why discriminating people in one
hundred countries have found the name on
gene the first word in buying a watch
the last word in satisfaction
and yet you made by hand on all probably
give along j much or as little as
seventy one fifty
launching the world's most on it watch
the world's most on target
we near a product of the launching with
know what happened
since eighteen sixty six
maker watches are the highest character
this is frank night reminding you that
launch a man with no watches
are sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to it
who proudly display this template
agency fought on jamie whitten or what
it time for the long gene pronto
had television journal of the important
issues of the hour
brought three oh every monday wednesday
and friday
presentation problem on jane what's not
watch company
playground lawn jane the world's most on
a block
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on and on june
good evening this is frank dot
may i introduce our colette affairs for
this edition of the ron gene costco
marisa promising bs television used up
and those facts in this issue that that
there are time magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
ist even a metro
chairman of the democratic national
committee
well is the time is all good americans
knowing me
draws well faster and faster than the
political winds of time when the
chairman of both
usually
the pair they can foresee a trend so
i'll ask i guess tonight mister mitchell
as chairman of the democrats
do you really foresee a trend
yes i think so i've got probably as i
see two trends
one of them is a
uh... i think clearly definable
uh... that favors they
uh... democratic candidates in the
democratic party over the republican
party
but the other one uh... disturbs me and
that i'd keep hearing up
of uh... apathy and uh... of lower
registration and some areas than we
should live
what do you know you think there is much
excitement about this election and what
a little registration actually hurt you
i think that a high registration helps
the democratic party i think the people
of this country are predominantly
democratic
uh... i've believed that the situation
changes in part to some degree from one
place to another
citizen it pretty dangerous to
generalize i think mister mister
through excellent their issues do you
feel it'd give new these kind of new
strength that everybody is predicting
for you
what particular issue anyone while i
think there are a number of of um...
of the way pretty heavily with people
of one is a of course the economic ah...
issue
uh... whether people feel that they are
better or worse off with
the republicans and power and most of
them are
satisfied that there were so awful for
that
uh... they are uneasy a little
apprehensive about the future
i believe there is a basic issue as to
whether people feel left a our country
is more or less secure at the present
time than we were in fifty two and i
think that they are
uneasy again that
feel that their lives
secure
uh... there are also i was born a
growing anxiety on the part of the
many people
of modest means or average means that
there has been favoritism shown by the
a republican eisenhower administration
to was special groups
uh... to big business that's was
emphasized i believe
decidedly
uh... by the
secretary wilson remarks lightly by
being
dixon yates
uh...
deal
uh... the tax bill
uh... which
favorite people who receive dividends as
against those who
earn their money by
working and i factory or
uh... by wages or salary
well now you've made dixon gates pretty
much your own trademark connects
regarding the t_v_a_ contracts
pretty much by just asking questions are
you ever going to be prepared to step up
and offer testimony or facts in that
case live band repair done i uh...
suggest to you know i have been very
directly very
of positive an explicit in the
statements that
are have made
and they have been borne out in every
single
instincts
from the beginning by
they
testimony that has been given
uh... before the anti-monopoly
subcommittee and under a republican
senator liner
uh... by the news that we finally been
able to
get through leaks or
by the activities of newspaperman about
the various drafts of the contract
and i've course that i was writing one
chairman call asked me to testify i said
of course i'll testify anytime or
anyplace in many mister mitchell if
you're in control of the congress
and a member
the uh... that bill
what will happen to have the
accountability to many of the responded
now all day before they finally
established the they've sent the hearing
for november the fourth i was going to
say that they set the hearing for the
end of
early in september and then they advance
that august and then they cancelled it
now they've put it leon
uh...
the election i'm going up to binghamton
new york
and make a speech which is
and the town that uh... chairman cole
lives and it's in his congressional
district on saturday night i'll have
some more to say about it
well i don't know i think i'll answer
your question mister lewis or i don't
know
think that dixon yates is ever going to
build that plant
well you know here's something i don't
understand
uh... senator fulbright who is certainly
a good loyal democrat and had a great
deal of integrity has said that this is
a very fine contract and he's quite
happy with it
i think these misinformed
aren't think that uh... you should also
have in mind that ami
the one who lives in arkansas is not
unaware of the fact that there are
certain benefits to arkansas from having
the proposed plant built in that place
well i uh...
i'm sure that senator fulbright is
entitled to disagree with most of his
colleagues just as senator cooper i
republican disagrees with the
republicans
senator cooper is very
uh... anxious to align himself in
opposition to the dixon yates contract
mister mitchell a
i ask you a question about what you
actually do it now a national chairman
mastermind of the uh...
a national campaign because this is a
visa local campaign to what else do you
do decide to make speeches as national
chairman
well it seems that uh... uh... i have
uh...
part of the responsibility for raising
the money
which uh... bond which we carry on these
activities of the party
uh... being seems to me i'm embarq
planes are
speaking a good bet at the time it's
true but all are actually a large to the
largest part of the work
is in maintaining contact with
candidates and with the leaders of the
party and an administrative work and
they
uh... national committee all of them and
it seems to be fair money
out money coming in for the democratic
coming in all but there were still a
long way behind them you court will ever
match the republicans
bob where uh...
uh... doing a little ball a little
better and we've been very much
heartened by the response that people
have given a slightly
uh... that brings up of
another point though that
shows uh... illustrates the point i made
to you
on bob greene favoritism of all
uh... the republican but administration
through
of big business i dot A
and letter today you know that was sent
to us by a democrat who have been
solicited by some republicans
of four a contribution to the republican
citizens for eisenhower
newsletter came from a plan is as a
businessman are solidly behind our
efforts to keep that congress
sympathetic
uh...
and more favorable maintain a more
favorable atmosphere for business
i think that they have a little
well envelope it says the story in a
nutshell
and ken that they have a peanut
and then they say the money we are
asking from businessman is just peanuts
compared to what electing a republican
congress can mean to business your
business
uh... there's that
i'd say that's that
in a nutshell is uh... the philosophy of
the eisenhower republican
administration
letting other people as a whole lot of
our preference to businesses so circum
i think you put them under suspicion
about them
electorate generally
what about the popularity of the
president himself
mr mc farthing generated too
i think it's been a fact that i think
generally that uh...
most of the people of the country who
voted for him uh...
or who didn't vote for more xinhua laid
like into
succeeded like him to be president of
all of the people
it's uh... they sort of identify
themselves on our country's well-being
with having the while president get
along well
i don't think you gonna make much
difference in this campaign he hasn't so
far i don't think you will
but it may get hurt begets and what will
be for talking about the philosophy in
for a moment ago
love early in the campaign you
disassociated the democratic party from
the americans for democratic action do
you think that that's giving you an
extra strong push in the campaign
now although i are made it clear has a
think i should have a nine
point that they would uh...
ways to do that there are separate uh...
organization that there are no part of
the democratic party i made it clear i
thought that we're glad to have
their support that is that of
any group of loyal americans for our
candidates are our principles whenever
they agree with them
manner not running us more not running
them i don't think that made me
different
but if you do and then our in our uh...
activities if you do win in november a
lot element of the party you expect will
be in control of conservatives or the
liberals
why don't we give him
answer that question of those uh...
those terms
it all
i think that the democratic party
essentially has a liberal and
progressive
of political organization i think
there's a place an ad for conservatives
and indeed uh...
uh... there is a
uh... it would mop too much if there
were people of different points of view
will look at another way do you think
that a democratic victory would market
upsurge in the strength of the uh...
overawed republican
why do
i do i think that's uh... that's a very
important point i think that there's a
wide missus uh... conception
uh... that uh... a republican victory
would somehow help
president eisenhower
actually the republicans who are running
for office whose names are on the ballot
would say why this is a mandate for us
y c we best of the people like what
we're doing
and had more than half of them are
opposing the president
well that the democrats do win in
november eighteen people going to be
uh...
friendly to me i have a problem are you
going to be a hostile to them on the
grounds that uh...
faulty handed out what already alexander
or what
part of the program we're talking about
her he proposes
a great many of the
of parts of the
uh... congressional or record received
in support of democratic
of boats they couldn't have been
inactive the
without them
there many un
which they were opposed and i think that
same thing will happen again
idea certainly do not think that uh...
uh... there will be a disposition to
oppose for the sake of opposition
uh... we've known speaker rayburn and mr
uh... mister
senator
johnson made that clear air that uh...
we reject the suggestion that there
would be of cold war between the
president and the
congress it takes two to make a war and
we don't propose to
uh... enter into one with the president
of the united states
uh...
on political matters at the expense of
the american people charlie
thank you very much mister mister
there have been here it hadn't been
the opinions expressed on the loan to go
to scope where those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting problems go cause larry
lesser ann lewis back
our distinguished guest list even a
natural
chairman of the democratic national
committee
go on and on gene watches to own one of
the finest watches made anywhere in all
the world and yet unbelievably along
jing watch is not expensive there are
many outstanding models of launching
watches prices low as seventy one fifty
the choice of stuff models is almost
unlimited
for ladies launching creates a pretty
examples of the jurors are exquisitely
taste unfinished perfect for every grass
and for every occasion
often enlarging produces watches for
every requirement watches for dressing
for sport launching automatic watches
the most advanced in the world lunging
waterproof and shock resistant watches
for rugged service
bulging chronograph watches for
sportsmen and scientists
every launching watch
weather for a lady or for adjustment is
made to the unique standards of
excellence
which at one point on gene
and world fairground prices twenty eight
gold medals
highest honors for accuracy in fields of
precise timing
this statement is true throughout the
world
the launching watch on your wrist
is not only one of the finest watches
made anywhere in all the world
but equally important it's the watch a
pious prestige and unbelievably you may
all are probably given on gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most haunted watch
the world's most when i get
premium product of the logging would
know what's coming
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches are the highest gary
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the mounting problems
a television journal of the important
pieces of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching in the
world's most on it much
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world all night long here
this is ragnarok
reminding you that launch a man with no
watches
are sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading job
full proudly display their sample
agency fought on james witt
it's time for the long gene promising
a television journal of the important in
terms of the aisle brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday
presentation problem on gene what na
watch company
make a row malanje the world's most
honored watch
and whatnot distinguish companion to the
world honored laundry
good evening this is frank not
may i introduce taco editors for this
edition of the long gene costco
that of this error
of the c_b_s_ television news stuff
and august texture
chief editorial writer for the new york
ever patio
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable sterling gold
representative from new york
and chairman of the joint committee on
atomic energy
bruising full we're very eager to talk
to you about it i can't do tonight
but i wonder if you don't mind
explaining to us the difference between
the joint atomic energy committee at
which you were chairman and the atomic
energy commission
the commission atomic commission is the
agency of the executive
branch of government
which has the responsibility of
administering the atomic energy law
the joint committee
is uh... as the word joint indicates
a committee of the congress composed of
nine senators and nine members of the
house
which uh...
is charged by the law with the
being constantly informed of with
respect to the atomic energy program
and at the joint committee considers any
revisions in the atomic energy act
usually one is a legislative committee
the other is an executive and you had
their full cooperation
between you and leave it and the
commission has really been amazing
mister actions the
fine spirit of cooperation that has
existed from the very beginning
between the uh... commission and the
legislative committee
there's a loophole it seems that one of
the greatest events to me that uh... you
people have been faced with is the
president's offer to set up a joint
pool of atomic energy for peacetime uses
and uh... i think now that the russians
have made a counterproposal to present
eisenhower's offer
in which they state they would that they
would do desire
amoral band on the use of atomic weapons
just as there was a moral ban on the use
of poison gas in the last one i do think
that that is acceptable
buffet wasn't exactly a counter-proposal
as i understand mr saurabh
the russian position has always been
that uh... the nations of the world
should outlawed the use of atomic
weapons
her reply to the eisenhower plan
that uh... the participants the
conferees
consider
the outlawing of atomic bomb
now with that i can find no disagreement
that the conferees give consideration to
i'd do hope very however that they their
considerations not serious norm nor long
life
wanted me first it
ask for a scrapping of atomic
weapons and the uh... stepping other
means of a production but now they seem
to want any moral ban on the use of them
although they would be
ready as weapons of retaliation
that was uh... the russian
counterproposal to the group plan
that uh...
the countries theater countries having
atomic weapons to
before goldie use of them
when you see on her convert her
condition of the uh... with respect to
the eisenhower planned his along the
same line what do you think that could
be acceptable to this country after all
would we be depriving us sales of the
only weapon in which we are superior to
the russians
that's why i feel are conferees should
be able to work to consideration to the
to the uh... suggestion i would be
unthinkable for us to ever agree not to
use the atomic weapon
it might not become a time when the too
part of the world will roughly equal in
atomic weapons and on the logic might be
to ban them
i don't think that timing uh... would
necessarily have arise
because it is conceivable that
to two countries russia and ourselves
may have
and an offensive potential that would
neutralize the other
then please uh... the advantage would
shift
to that country which placed the same
degree of emphasis on the use of atomic
energy for defensive
as was used for offense
who keys the former head of the atomic
energy commission uh... david in paul
has suggested that
if we can't come to any agreement with
the
soviet union on the eisenhower proposal
for a joint pool of atomic energy for
peacetime uses
we should go along with the western
world and set up such an agency
how do you feel about that that's
exactly the feeling i have heard from
the time president eisenhower
made his pronouncement
but at least we cannot allow
too
successfully upset the eisenhower plan
it is so essential
that the countries of the world's unite
and pool their knowledge in their
efforts
to using atomic energy for the
government
that we can't allow any recalcitrant
belligerent country to interfere with
because so much good can come from
it's been very much like the marshall
plan which the russians
refused to come into
were unable to wreck
it's somewhat like the marshall plan
except there is the distinction as i see
it
we're not giving
away too
countries of the world something of
extreme value
what we are giving now is
is information in advance
to these other countries
we're getting them knowledge that they
all would eventually learn some time
wilma security standpoint there is a
nickel
could we give away some of our tonic
fuel to a agency for joint international
usa while the russians still used to be
a atomic energy for the making of bombs
could we keep up our lead in the atomic
grace if we did that i don't uh... and
version that the eisenhower plan would
uh...
measurably interfere with our stockpile
of atomic weapons and certainly if i
thought that it did
uh... jeopardize our national security
as would never
but conversely would say then
but if they are in power plant goes into
effect
it will cut down the amount of atomic
weapons in the world world cup and
russia's atomic
weapon highlighted by the way back
problem remains unsolved
it will interfere and to some extent
with the uh... talent pool
potential of whatever country has that
potential but not in a in a great degree
sincerely contributions will be the
largest leo
well so if we didn't work out this plan
with the russians wouldn't we be giving
them away because uh... some of the
know-how on the industrial use of atomic
energy
some of the know-how which they might
not get otherwise
assuming which i think to be the fact
that uh... russia does not have the
knowledge
constructed productive uses of atomic
energy that we had
if the eisenhower plan is put into
effect and russia participates then of
course russia is going to benefit by it
much more than we will
russia has nothing to give us i think
uh... from this kind of standpoint of
using atomic energy for peacetime
missions
it wouldn't russia then be able to play
a peacetime use
peacetime engines and speak and put it
in a submarine
and making broken a four out of it
of course you could just the same as any
other country
to whom we might
give this knowledge and uh... allow the
use of the fissionable material
but as i say heat
desire for war the need for war becomes
greatly lessened
as this great new forces used for
production on things
for which people go to war represent a
cool what is your idea how this plan
would actually work with me and
international agency
setup
factories are plans for the making of
uh... nuclear fuel around the world all
the actually put up industrial plants to
create electric energy and who would
almost plants
that is this one of the details that
this uh... conference must uh... work on
maya
my own thinking is that uh... the
international organization
may either
own and operate the plants
or the international organization may
simply supervise plans
a country which has need for anatomic
uh...
our plan for the plight of the
international agency
they need
the international agency would
consider conditions
and above all
thought that ate one of these projects
must be
self-sustaining must be self liquidating
must be a profitable
enterprise
to get away from this uh...
w_p_a_ aspect and giveaway aspect it
must be something constructive
when i ask you a legal do you think that
uh...
the eisenhower plan that would be
encounter any opposition in congress if
the russians went along with us
the plan
has so much
in it that appeals to that
decency of people in the world
that i just can't believe that
any american or any member of congress
would seriously protest providing
the american people and the congress an
all time
are sured that this plan will not
interfere with the national security
which nobody wants
there nobody expects the plan
jeopardy rash supported it
growth hyper growth but change the
subject of people still unaccounted
entity
it is a bounce that
yesterday we were growing two divisions
from korea
does not have uh...
any relationship to developments in the
atomic field
and it can
atomic weapons
be a substitute for manpower
in the long run
i think mister picture that
the more we uh...
improve our atomic capacity
greater versatility we chief and atomic
weapons
good last will become the need for foot
soldiers
however i don't think there was any
connection between the decision to
uh... withdraws two divisions from
correa has any relationship to
the use of atomic weapons
bascue identical its
all conditions were favorable towards
the eisenhower planet its acceptance by
the russians we work everything out how
long would actually take before such a
a program could be worked out for the
beneficial use of atomic energy
well takes about three years to build a
anatomic
power plant
are expected if the conferees the get
together reasonably soon but i a
summertime
or fall formulate their plans
designs can be worked out
by nineteen fifty-five
construction started in the summer fall
fifty five or so that perhaps within the
next four or five years
we can anticipate
anatomic are planted anyplace in the
world of the country that
as need for it
will be an operation bullies norplant's
be competitive with that
other types of fuel cold water power
all yes of course dot that's the uh...
that's the goal that were all working
for us to make them competitive
so that the countries of the world which
have no calls i have no water resources
can't have nevertheless have electrical
energy
to make the things that the people need
the final question everything paula let
me ask you
we all off right netting of the atomic
bomb spassky do you think that the
public should have more information
about the peaceful uses of atomic energy
that's one of the appealing aspects of
the guys in our plan
is to start the minds of people thinking
in the direction of how we can use this
for the good of mankind
and the people should know
at the same force can be used for the
good of people
to a greater degree than for the
destruction people
already more lives have been saved by
the use of atomic energy than has ever
been destroyed and the two explosions in
japan the people don't generally realize
that
and yet at the field of medicine is
scarcely been touched
in the field of preserving foods
in areas where they don't have uh...
like device boxes and so forth it has
great possibilities to say nothing of
generating electricity
for manufacturing goods that people need
the peacetime uses art
without mint
and the people should
thank you very much for example the
being here with us tonight
the opinions you're our speakers
expressed tonight a band kar liya karo
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting problems built was larry
lucerne and august texture
our distinguished guest
closely i will stay wrinkles
representative from new york and
chairman of the joint committee on
atomic energy
why not invest part of that christmas
bonus in a new launching watch
indiagen head you'll be mighty glad that
you did
believe me
it will be a proposition
among the world's finest watches
launching alone has one ten world's
fairground prizes twenty eight gold
medals and so many honors for accuracy
the dependability abhimanyu launching
watch
will be a revelation
gone will be the uncertainty about time
and every launching watches style with
good taste to make a commanding
appearance on the wrist
the most important whether you pay as
little as seventy one fifty for a long
gmail nicole pillowcase
or several hundred dollars for one
studded with diamonds it will be made to
the unique plunging standard of
excellence
which made lounging in fact
the world's most haunted watch
the world's most on target
and throughout the world no other name
on a watch
means so much as launching in the
world's most on it wants
premium product of the long-chain would
not want to come
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches are the highest debt
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
bullet on jane carson
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
brought to you on the top of laundry in
the world's most honored watch
and weapon on distinguished companion to
the world all that long jane
this is frank night reminding you
that long jane and whatnot watch
are sold in service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leaving joe
will proudly displayed is up
agency follow on jamie whitmore watch
big time for the long gene promise toh
had television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday
presentation of the long game but no
much government
maker ltb on jane the world's most on a
block
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world
honored laundry
good evening this is frank night
may i have reduced our collateral for
this edition of the monthly incomes phil
from the c_b_s_ television news the
larry mister
and walter cronkite
our distinguished guests this evening is
key coleman m
commissioner of internal revenue
mister anders you've been on this job of
collecting our taxes for the morning
here now
quiet about it
before i ask you about the
work you've done so far michael s
just what your qualifications were for
this
vitally important folks
maybe i should say fresh that they're a
lot of people don't think i've been sick
glad about it
than that and that uh...
i'm basically a course uh... an account
uh... management modernization has been
my bonus for a long time and i've taken
several experiment from
practice in through public affairs
and uh... addition of that i have
administrative responsibility and the
military services and wrinkled in law
and i am like to thank at least that the
president the secretary informed me
because they think that we did they
job they did the past throughout i hope
that originally also democrat to a large
acer
a trailer conservative democrat
we're commissioner
in this year that you've been on the job
review
discovered any evidence with the
american public is involved in
widespread
shirking of their duty and vision tracks
nollie happen and i i i don't think they
are some of the fact
because we
we have a rama interesting situation in
this country
we found that the average american
taxpayer
uh... has a pretty high respect for his
government's willing to carry his share
of the role of the cost of it
and if it were not for that
and i'm afraid that we would not in
trouble long time ago we figure that
about ninety seven percent of all the
people in this country
pay that tax is uh...
voluntarily agreed we call it voluntary
compliance that come up that text and
times of mister tax collector
is what uh... figure my income is enough
for you thank you so much inheritance
to might help define for me
a communist country n forward
stability of its tax system comes to
commit i'm afraid that most of the
fealty
other fellows getting away with
the more than we are now
is there any against listing every
possible reduction in expenses on your
income tax
you know nothing against and we want
people to do that week
we want every taxpayer to get the
benefit of ever deduction that the law
allows in and where there are optional
ways of
computing once actually want him to have
the wave that is least expensive to him
it will take the least amount of money
out of his pocket presence
taken out of the standard deduction
there may be
in most cases the
away jenna will take the standard
deduction because it's simple he doesn't
have to worry about itemizing his
defection but suppose
somebody has a
a badge fell on the list in the in his
doctor's bill and hospital bills run-up
file may be something
disasters occurs to a close-up of that
condo is house catches fire
uh... that sort of person should
sat down and make his deductions in
detail sources say well an obvious to me
that managed to take them that way all
the claim the standard deduction of ten
percent
when you have a way of together that we
want him to take your view of their
money people nonsense overpayment toxins
by
of mob completely understand inflexible
they have no doubt about that is not a
matter of feeling good
there aren't that many people who paying
for instance shit
in the taxpayer can bus it we've talked
about
do you have a lot about
we found that many people who have
overpaid as well as a lot of course who
hadn't paid an awful and didn't bring it
all
and we picture every uh... make many
reforms too
all types of taxpayers' individuals
corporations and partnerships trusts and
so on
indicating that
an excess payment of taxes
might have a lot of house-to-house
canvassing whose mentioned uh...
some newspapers problem operation snoop
called estoppel methods that you want
around asking people left their homes
whether or not the intended taxes and
uh... and demanded proof that they have
in store for numbering close actually
doing your campus one of the accomplish
there
well list operations noble cause we love
them
oracle
journalists again denied
of course if i were newspaper reporter
i'd be pretty proud of having a bit
about what actually looks at it and
whether that's
and all what we do is to go from one of
the land
hecho on
well not people
at each other teams have father account
it's not a smoked in any sense is no
biting into people's homes
anything of that kind
we're going go on the home unless we
invited the men don't usually go up
if a person declines to answer our
questions and uh... more than someone
they don't have to learn
there's no hard feelings on on the bus
park we don't get mad at anybody about
it
and the fact of the matter is that has
been about pleasant experience
we've had uh...
well i remember in new england and the
entire
canvas up there in the first month
when it first came to light that
seem to be something unusual which it
wasn't
was because it explosive
on that subject than on the books and
his friend phone since nineteen and
twenty six
we didn't have been a difficult it was
on the one person and several thousand
leavin
who seem to get
beyond happy about it
it's not a smoke
is marian effort to find out that
everybody is on the tax rules and
should be on
so that everybody will pay his fair
share of the taxes
as congress intended and i
our reaction or other
experience is that the average person is
glad to know
that this uh...
insemination being made by us
everybody is going to be paying just
like he is
i might say that
since we started that uh... rather since
we visit on that
is being done elsewhere no right now for
instance of one st and one important
city where exactly the same thing being
done on the state level in the first
instance in on the local level in the uk
my signature what exactly
what exit
technologies you cracking down on the
radio standing forms of innovation
well of course the people that uh...
that we have particularly interested in
after handing only text dodging aspect
of it on the people who did limit set
out
two of the very end that payment of that
taxes
either by not filing a return of all
or else by
the understating their income all the
stating that the duct
and uh... i'm sure if we had time on
this program to read
just some of the cases to let people see
what was happening and we know about
about the wisdom impropriety of what
we're doing to catch the evite
robert there's like one of the economy
where there's more pollution than on the
other
well uh...
uh... i think that question could
probably answer the firm actively
usually find of course it
uh... in the people engaged in the legal
pursuit research they don't want to
disclose their income
probably cause ur
they just don't operate on me
on the legal basis in the first place
and secondly because perhaps uh...
predicted that way
then there
the illegal activities would become
known and become subject oh caught up
with a long
on there
criminal for serbs probably tournament
let's take another break tricky for me
to make a sellout
mister commissioner but we don't think
it's pretty uh...
uh... though on the challenger on that
cruise gone with the military planning
at that time i figured i'd love that
amid much must be having to get back at
it on the red for prisons
which i would like to high school
students we find that they make one
proposal in areas of the average
taxpayer
so in high school students can make this
i'm pretty sure that the average
and our taxpayer can draw firstly
harlequin titles on the performers perot
nobody had one classroom race that is
seven two five percent of
those kids have to pay taxes and
endorsing some of the house listed as a
commission of one of the main prisons
i've heard against income tax laws that
they seem to favor the businessman and
are not the wage-earner most of us the
salary
makers and we just maker legitimate
business deductions but it seems rather
unfair that the uh...
the man in business can make more
depreciation method
focus on its face i suppose that's true
but uh...
you have to get down to the bedrock
economy
or economics of the question that card
uh... anything that is done too
simplify the problem of the news in
complying with his tax obligation
through downtown from that led to the
credit
of the individual
quiet because
or taxes that i know nothing about
accepted state in gift taxes
uh... goes into the cost of product
which the individual has to bar
and he may not
did he may think that the
been identified as a get more than a fit
because that's where they
simplification of cars actually what
happens is that
in the final analysis keep getting an
indirect benefits by law
cost of the things he has to buy it
plus not correct to say that though
because you change
a push low-tech spin is that
is unfairly individual that's a very
sharp said in our point of a lot of our
people stay in show business where their
talents do tend to depreciate we take an
actress susan beauty may be her
chief talent now it was rather unfair to
renew
unfairness
well i think that's a very unfortunate
situation but that brings up a brother
interesting question
and ideas suit as a desk where i fit
into the tax picture
we are they
and forces of the tax law
it's up to us to collect the taxes that
congress
says
shelby cool evidence aston collective
a problem that kind of the matter of tax
policy
congressman herman's tax policy in the
final analysis
administration
acting through the second iteration
undersecretary
determine who should pay what taxes and
at what rate
therefore problem that kind even though
it may be distressing is not one that i
have a nepal to correct it has to be
corrected by highland park and of course
congress has to accept
and suggestion on that score
the final question mister andrews what
advice could you give the average
wage-earner to uh...
make his deduction up we prove it to the
uh... your collectors
the average wage and of course
his taxes a little
so he doesn't have a particular problem
on how much sex
or pay
i think i am repression ought to keep a
pretty good record of what they spend so
that if at the end of the year
use of the advantage of claim that the
documents in detail
they would do that government claimed
that ten percent
overall
deduction on standby sync with the same
under that way
thank you thank you very much mister
commission and is in the provisional
united
thank you so it's been a play the race
the opinions that you've read our
speakers expressed a lot of an entire
liberal
the editorial board for this edition of
the loan gene promise bilbao's
maraniss earn and walter cronkite
our distinguished guests
busty coleman and rooms
commissioner of internal revenue
a priceless attribute of every launching
watched his pride of possession
it bring to a tone of the satisfaction
of knowing that he owns a lot of highest
christie's
among the finest watches of all the
world
along team lots brings more than to the
life of a beautiful possessions
more than the unsurpassed timekeeping
over a marketwatch
for that long j much of yours is the one
and only world's most on it much
phony long being among the finest boxes
of the world
as one can world program prizes
twenty eight gold medals highest honors
from government observatories and of the
nation of preference
infarcts aviation and in fact
forty eastern for a graduation an
anniversary of earth day four and a
important duplication noel and they want
to watch means so much as maundy
and yet unbelievably you made by handles
more probably given on gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
laundry in the world's most on iraq
the world's most on again
premium product of the laundry and
whatnot watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of waters of the highest character
this is frank night reminding you that
long jane and with no watches console in
service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leaving do it
who proudly display this template
agency bought on gene but na locks
there is only one that most the
perpetual motion top created by the
cooper atmos runs without winding
without electricity powered only by
unfailing daily variations in the
temperature of the air
atmos product off the code for a
division of long game with god
it time for the long jeanne calment
a television journal of the important
thing to do the eye
brought to you every monday wednesday
and friday presentation of them onto a
much more watch company
maker of long jane the world's most on a
block
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on and on june
good evening this is frank nightmare
introduce our calendars for this edition
of the mondrian cosco
they are c_b_s_ news correspondents
larry mister and walter cronkite
our distinguished guest for this evening
at three colin n
connection there are the internal
revenue
as our guest tonight would be the first
to admit
nobody knows the tax collector
well it's a bit of taxes all within the
realm of politics
job of mister andrews is to see that we
paid no more or no less
then where budget do by law
estimates just as the deadline for
filing income tax returns is still a few
days away if you have any idea how many
people haven't found it
well mall not
not exactly how many have not
file but
we've been keeping in
pretty close touch with that from time
to time
and of course we won't know until after
the april fifteenth deadline has passed
for individual juneau corporations
passed on fifteen th of march
verbally or model after that april
fifteenth deadline has passed and we
started the results of msi what would
pander filed in each
to the following period
just exactly what the patent school will
be
we do know that a lot of people have
been fired yet who should have
if you know that
yes we do know that
people will be in people as we always
are they they've taken advantage of
only opportunity which they were
supposed to have
we'll have another thirty days ago
nothing else and i think i should say
that all those folks who have violet
the people at work in the revenue
service you are not themselves almost
two and a filing kernan
uh... i hope no one is going to
think that i should be a insisted drove
people work
all the time between now and april
fifteenth and on take care of people who
have a good
more properly and now
rather wait until the last minute let
the extension of the mister andrews of
the uh... planning period for another
month
that of any help to the uh...
revenue service
yes it has been
it's been a tremendous help to us as
well as a video help to the taxpayers
helped us in this way
we have to keep in mind a lot of time
at all times what out two main problems
on the one is to collect taxes
and number two who is to uh...
again after those people who
inclined to hold back on us and those
who though they don't pull back and
applauding nevertheless
this don't like to pay taxes
many other books
and i think it slows down those two
efforts
psa nonetheless in the patient
so what we what we have been able to do
with this
extended time period is too
keep more about people that their
regular pass
and therefore we've been able holed up
collections and
holed up in fact the increase the number
of examinations made of tax returns
we have to some extent gotten rid of
that
running on mister andrews of morals are
going to get shocked because it was like
a month
we've been given
it sure does
you know we've been on a problem of
filling up bala
auditing organization now
examiners for
on l_a_ eighteen months now
and we expect to go right on up to the
point where we will probably have about
the
places many
feel a lot of things that we had
two years ago a eighteen months ago
and probably
uh... half again waala
as
fraud investigators and we have at that
time
and i might say that
when improved auditing methods
uh... and they need
increased costs
we expect to
exam on fortran movement in return for
twice the number of people
four percentage of the
total number of people putting in
returns we'll get checked them without
and i want you like to know that habit
ya back atcha broadcast let me get
through this morning we are
wouldn't go on a happy what happens is
that read many people
return don't have to be checked the
clinton and congress their entire from
withholding than we know what that is in
the north texting or
then that we get off the scale
the probability of being checked
increases
room in proportion to the presence of a
number of factors which we don't intend
to go into so that i'll say that's not
as we increased our staff
are jamming staff
and as we improve our methods
the probability
uh... in iran
and not getting checked is diminishing
by reference
don't you go to a point where the
cost of the uh... collecting of the
taxes
if the diminishing return for the amount
of taxes collected reaction it there is
no longer mission return without say
this we havent reach that point you have
and i'm not that they have gone
river come across that bridge when we
get no if i may say so mister
commissioner
some people think that the nineteen
fifty four tax returns that are
extremely complicated one editorial so
that they were the most complicated in
the whole history of income
do you think that criticism
what would you like to me too
say what i think of that particular
statement
i think that particular statement was
made more to create effect than it was
too
show any evidence of having them instead
of the situation
and uh...
as part of that
provocation generally is concerned
though you probably interested to know
that actually
that has been relatively little
criticism
that they returned from more difficult
than they have them in the past now
there's only one would good reason for
that matter is that they stopped any
more difficult than they've been in the
past
the exception of to schedule
you know we now have a credit for
dividends in the credit for retirement
income
no one was criticized those returns
share has suggested that we leave those
those calculations off about mister
and no one has to get to them a better
way to do it than we've provided
solely on the complaint on that that
uh... that are essentially different
from last you know that's prompt him for
that bill for the follows the
affair sized improvement on one
weekend for you how
which is for the
the spot taxpayer mansion income up to
five thousand dollars who want to take
the standard deduction of ten percent
that's just the perfect for my income
tax
former then about a devastating
nam that's not just my opinion
representatives of
eighty five different governments in the
world of the bank to lash out tell us
that
it's really than simplest thing about it
over the bop
but decided it would check made on the
card so it could be processed manually
or
financially do you want
detached
threatened by a simple question
questions that anybody can answer
contains no copulation
we do all the work
soul really from outside of five million
people we've made the job of allot
easier
and we shouldn't have made it in a more
difficult
for the rest of mixed up
to the extent
that we'd have to provide
uh... a means of creating some of the
credit should congress in this desire to
give some relief
and given by me
developed in nineteen fifty four
offender thirteen fifty or try to figure
out
how much each investigator these new man
you're talking about how much he's
investigators should bring in
in order to pay for his own salary and
expenses where we don't
we don't think you know how much you
should bring in which we know how much
he actually about uh...
uh... actually what happens is as we put
a new man on man in the first year after
he has
vendors job
and i think you quite a few months to
get him up to that point
your problem
bring in ten to one
the next year
he'd get up to me that when it too
and then she goes on he might even get
to the point of
of hers but she says that in product to
run some old friends since of allah
investigators
produce as much as a part of a million
dollars in revenue a year
and they only get paid about ten
thousand dollars
cc that's twenty five to one
that what they bring in depends upon how
good they are not a word we don't
concentrate we'll save a bit of rain so
much money we checked and you've got to
be a good agent
if he's a good agent that money comes as
a matter of course
using a hero
oversimplifying the amount of
bookkeeping required by those in
middletown higher income brackets
subject for those who are
independent contractor so to speak
professional men doctors lawyers and
uh...
radio announcers people like that they
give you a freakin sumo
right through that may explain a little
bit on that
the fact of the matter is that
not nearly as many people keep
the records they should
uh... as
we would like to see is a matter of fact
that's in over half of the people who
should keep some kind regards don't
now then uh... how can you simplify
something for somebody who isn't already
doing what he should be done
and moreover you can't separate
by the dole people in the quietness of
attack someone to discipline by the law
itself
with a twenty dollar
across the board of health care problem
any every gone through the
it would have played havoc with us
administrative we would withhold that
simpson was guilty than we've been
with have abandoned
i don't believe that with the ministry
of a possible for us the family
well since there are
several days left for work
twenty million taxpayers i guess to file
their returns mister andrews any advice
to give them now
knew that i do i i have some advice to
give them
waterfall awhile please get out and then
get the job although well and all that
the last minute because uh...
on that last minute arrives
uh... we guess can get to everybody that
wants to be helped
we have all kinds of facilities for
nothing
everybody
provided bill come out of soon
with a reasonable spread of fighting
and not all at one time
and we just can't do anything for those
who don't show up on time
and the clinton after managed to make
considerably the standards of the person
s for an extension on filing their
returns
here's an invitation for an
investigation
no sir
monaco
thank you very much like to go on and it
was
the commissioner of internal revenue
thank you very much um... related to
offend you
the opinions expressed on the monkeying
crossed over those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching crustal was larry was
their and water cronkite
our distinguished guest list he coleman
andrews commissioner all the internal
revenue
though the game has perfected after
twenty years of development what are
regarded as the world's most advanced
automatic watches
the excuse of upset winding mechanism is
fabricated with perfection
which represents a new trial chronology
and craftsmanship now we are facts that
you should know
the automatic watches wong by the north
of the potential
now this diagram
represents the winding roads were of
many automatic watches say how it moves
in all eight parts of this error
uh... that diagram represents the law
and jane automatic
it has a full swing
three hundred sixty degree winding road
every movement of the rest
produces winding action
design however is only the beginning of
the lodging automatic
what makes it on team wants those who
probably fine is the unsurpassed
protection of maggi manufacture which at
one foot on jane damn well sad ramprasad
twenty eight gold medals
more hard for accuracy than any other
time
if finest quality at your press
consideration
then whatever your need to know watch
whatever this time whatever the parks
well jean has made a point
forever young kmart will demonstrate in
full measure the greater accuracy and
completeness liability which made
lounging in the world's most haunted
watch
the world's most on it yet
premier product of the laundry and
whatnot what happened
since eighteen sixty six
maker watches ally of character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
poor but on jamie crops
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast
on behalf of long jane the world's most
honored watch
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world on
a daunting
this is frank not reminding you that
lawn jame and whatnot watches are sold
and service from coast to grow
by more than four thousand leading to
others
who proudly displayed as emblem
agency fought on jane what norwalk
sign for the launching
television journal of the important
issues of the office
socially liberal monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what stuff
later on
lunging
the world's most common law
and what noor distinguished from family
and for the world on is on gene
good evening this is frank night
may i introduce our photos for this
edition of the launching cosco
mister william bradford healing editor
of the american mercury and mister
hennelly has left contributing editor of
newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening as mister three of them are
caught
former assistant united states attorney
general
promise to call them now that you were
back in the private life and done with
being a bureaucrat
perhaps you can tell us something about
the pressures that were brought on new
when you were assistant attorney general
what kind of pressures are they
for the chance of the french as well i
was sitting there for the mission
if you can understand that
but they came largely from the summit of
the congressman almost continously
from the
prominently in public life that
normal here
they come in the form of telephone calls
and visits or what
we have a number of of communications of
course work over the telephone
but there were many many conferences
that were head with services
and congressman
in my office and if so they have the
allure
is so busy i would accommodated you'll
go to his office
what would be a typical request
sukru quince
with tax cases for example involved
o_d_s_ when i was in the tax division
text you should be barred by i remember
one no
who's troubled me a great deal of what
was one of greater than love dot
one was one of the american
rushing to do another man have quoted
germany found that with the vice
president would be called me about both
of you there live
quarta-feira fratricide
one so he was he was uh...
he was concerned about the
the interests of this fellow
cannot deliver but if you can see the
about-face keys was sick of sodium six
armed it was wrong
enough to win that uh...
the doctors
mcgovern's office prevent
that the ordeal of which i would not
result in the jet was definitely there
was no other alternative but to go ahead
with his view cameras part of that that
is very little
further for our viewers of course your
this antonio you're from north carolina
aptly instances of financial that's four
years your word
and in a uh...
text-based the department of justice has
uh... here that day
say it started ada prosecutor attacks
case
does just that
yes so you know that that's what brought
you are now all these precious that's
right um...
un forces you to do is keep this
power to another homeless in your
absence
and you really have to say that all is
committed to add a appearing on the
president several directed at me
yes uh... improvement solely
etiquette
michigan uh... i thought that uh...
medicare faces
taken every friday all is good friends
you're going to have good friends
because she was also
until the problem is with the with the
when the ah...
when he left me out
takes lecture if there is flat president
saying the geographic
into the booth such space
well
switchable for secular arab years ago
restore your
date may three rd you're you're right
uh... he's got a watch by quoted well
she got out it was page one twenty to
thirty five within the last part
as uh... leonard and victoria toensing
you most believe abuses did
usually has a meeting
mother loses
along with the so uh... we went for so
long
and she argued that
to unless the ten-year as this room of a
to be renovated guest one so you know
that it was all right
i thought it was time to get me the
toshiba
or specific days
where you charged with whenever u
outside activities
i've been trying to find out mister
outside activities what
that just means the rent rate is for
your friends i've idon't know is one of
those things that uh... the president
ought to know that uh... gentleness with
grandpa tribe found i've been trying to
find out
both the house at the flow of
domestic or you're out and i don't know
at the end of one of the committee
hearings the chairman of the
subcommittee eight congressman king a
year ago
resurgence judy and recreation you're
trusting the done irreparable damage to
the government now
what is your comment on that state he
said he said i hadn't i have done he'd
do send this to my blog
and i've seen you wish to have it with
women
chairman sees when she made a remark
he he he did give service to his
government and he did a disservice to
the honorable people effectively
anytime i get stephenie
minutes actually was using in the four
years here
iran test expectations you have any
cases that you asked me to japan's of
props with sixteen thousand suitcases
probably forty five percent will
compromise instead of
and of talks between five hundred income
tax fraud case
saying that these cases easier
at activist last year's
uh... you get calls from members of
congress uh... during this period
payroll didn't you call yourself
and those members of congress is a
warning to to uh... favorably consider
their constituents asap
yeah so they had that's a part of the
system only unstable label
of strong representation has been made
to the chapman the war on the ball and
all of that relations with the
of the world consider some of them was
convinced that uh... i was about to do
the justice by died in someone
and of course i will try to convince a
congressman and i had little to the
before the fact was so strong you just
had to be done but i'd like to take up
one specific case let's take the case of
the kansas city votes rowlands
now you were in on that for awhile
that's why you paldon by anybody or did
you stepped in by yourself
most of the changes to the ymca
investigation
costumes from
of the many calls that we received we
have complaints from individuals out in
the congressional district
that uh... congressman expelled
that comes from strong how does this was
a nineteen forty six year so that was
when i was not an axe felt was the uh...
congressman act at the democratic
candidate for president truman favorite
yes and it was it was argued that fraud
was used to elect him although his
democratic opponent was a case here so
that i was a case a friend a lot of the
to do is done about it in kansas city
early and then it came to your attention
several yes right
as a rack
just that way of information
uh... how does a man whose dentistry
could turn it down
how does the get positions such as you
have to private watching some senator
frank you there
most of them
most so it's a had anything to do with
my road weston
mister clark told me
would like to google office as you know
the state's attorney had lou is really
the united states and win
he would want to fill the vacancy
that he created by accepting
the the attorney joseph of the country
but he said that because of this for the
record which i had made
well he talked with the president
as we have decided to extend the
invitation to be in that was far i came
to washington
anew the semester who who was it was
written or something
of the names of the baby
i mean the world get one though
of about the invitation from of course
we can still meet with the seemed
impressed with the next year to get this
such a position
clay at this stage over in itself
is millions of dollars in tax cases all
of these calls that u_p_s_ white house
for members of congress
that's inherent in our system misplaced
yes those kids and if he is on
verity
ferret normal
one who has
who has to make the decision
he has two faces
two sources are attracted a lot a lot
like to get back to the to the specific
cases we took up because i think because
harry five the whole situation
if we went into something like that say
the kansas city cold case now you were
called in on that and you
stayed in for a while and then you were
taken office
we are right and wrong what what
happened with the heads it was
that uh...
this live in their investigation this
preliminary investigations they couldn't
find a famous memoranda
memorandum
the f_b_i_ has been completed his
spokesman investigation is the embracing
allah kansas city hall yet so we can use
it if you can reaching the investigation
to consider stuff
yes we had uh...
assist investigators
and there were eight thousand people
interviewed him out of that number of
for eighteen hundred fifty-four
affidavits were taken
and that was a part of the preliminary
investigation report to me by the f_b_i_
because we have a lot of these things
you turned it over to the f_b_i_ round
we asked them to investigating the
x_-two too
too
to make a preliminary investigations
sold
at the to determine
because we believe we have teeth
investigation it would cost a spanking
sum of money because we think that calls
for mostly about that no president call
you all fat investigation a little his
orders if you were called on pablo
normal
unlike most of
uh... i was uh...
obviously i never seem to communicate
with the white house firm in his source
and we all really believe that the facts
were not sufficient to warrant if other
investigation because we could not find
way out
that was in the air with the two more
people conspired together to possible
right
distraught
one of the important thing to do you
have any bears that were in the last two
or three weeks you bunco undergone
extensive investigation worsened by the
chair of committee
afterwards germiston shelf uh...
at more or less rendered this judgment
and which he said that your quote an
honest man who is indiscreet in his
associations
an eight triumphant former physicist
junior marol climate of washington canal
it
is that a fair
description is
of your experience essex well
i know that the chairman admitted
keating was right with basic to the
american people i was and on his neck
however disagree with that
at all and i know they're right
as both of the security of marathon
washes will secure your if
he was the most peculiar
i think you're right there you will love
to keep his most peculiar mark lambert
you front it is stated what everybody
who gets off at union station awful
only popped his call
comes in from the national airport
he goes to washington for something
and he disappointed if he does not
take it home with casey
and i'm sure that there are fears very
much appreciate these frank statement
should you tonight sir thank you for
being with us
the opinions that you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight are entirely
as well
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise go falls mister
william bradford killing and mister
henry has a
our distinguished guests was mister
taylor markle former assistant united
states attorney general
products maker such as long gene recalls
that christopher columbus made his grade
voyages before the watch was invented
he's only timepiece
and our jobs
like this fifteenth century one which
happens to be the property of the haven
planetarium
this of course after the reverse
every half hour
now columbus day marks a milestone for
launching watches to
this gold medals was presented to long
gene that peace and love us columbian
exhibition which all of the four
hundredth anniversary of columbus's
discovery of america
now consider how consistently lawns he
marches have maintained their leadership
over the years long-chain
is the only watch in history to win ten
world's fair ground prizes twenty eight
gold medals and literally thousands of
awards for accuracy from great
government observatory
today's launching watches our our
clients
distinguished for explosive styling
and other fellas traditional promises of
accuracy and long life
for what's launching watches off world
up
trolling
throughout the world no other name on
the watch
means so much as long gene
the world's most vulnerable
premium product
for belong to a much smaller com
since eighteen sixty six maker of
watches all of the highest debt
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time colombian crops
a television journal of the important
dishes of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching in the
world's most holocaust
and what
more distinguished companion
oro valley launching
this is right now
reminding you that on election day
you are the most important person in the
past
cell exercise your privilege as an
american citizen
and both
for the candidate of yourself
uh...
or on or far far far
long-winded
on the market that one can wear a
program private
twenty eight gold medals and more on
this for accuracy than any other
countries
party the world's most honored watches
maidan guaranteed by the logging with my
wife company
time for the logging one of them
television general of the important in
terms of the up
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry in with your
wife and
later on
laundry
the world's most on and off
and went
the thing with companion for the world
on and on the
good evening
their contract not
they are that you thought the leather
for the position of the laundry in front
of
definitely proper part of that
and put a little bit particular uh...
editor of the american heart luau
honored guest leaving it would be a
cover-up looming on the plane general
ball a leader of the vote on the ground
in world war two
if it means expressed on that the
federal aid does of the speaker
of our
our product or forty s of course
note here is one of the great
underground leaders
of our generation
there are none an expert on underground
warfare
now sir uh...
and your name a great time
poland now
but thank-you to america
i was right
let's keep backing convicting wrapping
rescue package its case for appointment
i stay so you've been uh... your guest
in america now for a few weeks
and you are now living in london
family
by meeting mumbles
nineteen forty-five
we are of course
and know your story
uh... power earlier foliage on the
ground opposed
and uh...
then have the right hand
failed to come here he
that through the record waded into the
woodwork relentlessly
reserves uh...
and uh...
is there bitterness now in full and i
guess direct and
ways the problems
it's based on
using the word of the world
we are anxious to get your opinion sir
in america
our people
are fighting a great deal of hope
and the underground movement and the
satellite countries
and we'd like your opinions on the
nature of underground warfare
against the russians
now a
other russians more difficult to oppose
with underground methods in the germans
were
or a scene
pockmarked and wiser
yuan
please down the complete that
one hundred and around with popcorn
defense
i don't see it
incomparable movement
responsible for a long band
padi russians uh... more ruthless in
dealing with underground movement in the
germans worked
brown's with not experience of copco
nancy welcome from us
pickup truck and to know more about how
to combat found within twenty miles
there were all underground though
but that the title of the fact that
underground movement
what about
uh... underground property and uh...
what do you think of the burial are
shortwave radio reports of american
always attempt to get propaganda in
purple
does that give
spreading off
the support of the people who least very
careful
before he was coming from two to three
work whenever you are uh... fighting so
desperately against the german sir
where your people have made more hopeful
about the radio contact with the rest of
the world forty eight seats for you to
meet you
if you've been gone underground movement
impossible and pete
at mclean awaiting for order
lawyers for the war typing youtube
it's hard to montgomery yet thought
through her
when the war
bob birmingham i mean harpoon beer
expect the war
it's very difficult to accomplish
i don't expect the law
failure of the people you know
duffel forward
baltimore md completely normal
twenty-one
reflect what the world
roughly uh... fickle
www
properly boeing video thinks not
they won't be easily
why didn't they
two or three rd
next week or wee hours
or was he was from falls
newton food
the auction do people decide
whom i regard
our present efforts in europe as hopeful
sir
do you think that we are doing a hopeful
counterweight to russian power and
western europe
on the thirteenth
do you think it is possible for general
eisenhower to build an effective army
adam
frank donatelli
narrower
here in america great many people
were disillusioned after the second war
there were a great many americans have
regarded the russians as allies
and so they were bitterly disappointed
a betrayal
that the russians seem to be giving up
now where you people in
and poland has bitterly disappointed
when the russians as we were in america
rowell mafia
means your function pollutants into at
juku explode
in room three or four world
mcbroom moment after that double-crossed
your uprising
but you were surprised when they've
doubled crafter operating room
the complaint
careful into or political beliefs
at you at a military man
they had military must become the
recessed instantly
but it was a corporate reporting from
from from the defense went through
but it was a political decision that
result in your destruction
invincible for the police
marijuana returned from his current film
they wouldn't have to
afterward
mad about it
not to agree with me that it's about
factor to an ally in the past
after the state
what's up guys
here double-crossed
that was that about november nineteen
forty four of us
maybe conference if your withheld some
four months later life
now are
you people of course we're disappointed
at uh... what with what you call that
sell out it's not that way
eternal
think the frames
which was having a liberal
bitterly disappointed that the uh...
wavy
western allies seem to have sold out for
either of you know
if he thought
worked with him
what is the uh... position of the polish
prime and now you have some intelligence
of course in poland now haven't you
movers are coming from poland
we know what the
nearly political excerpts from a drop of
both
and other words you get
there is a polish army now isn't there
uses for those are all
and really loopholes i think that the
government
he said russian command and that would
be the there directions from major on
that
engineer information
wouldn't that be pretty weak
family rely on our fell in march
for every american i don't think
these are new the available to stop he
would hate to have a very high and it
wouldn't be
one of the possibly the parents of the
russians and from starting the war is
after one question there
americans have heard a great deal of
ethical
correctly massacre
uh... we were told that first of the
germans have deal with the
a great many point out this is
are you convinced it was the russians
who destroyed the polish officers
i was convenes
than a gold teams
wonderful findings replacing protecting
from fault the stupid
english-speaking own investing will
bring before
he moves in repeating seen prepping
promises they make it
broke now
abroad
and it was russian propaganda do tell
that's in the western world
that those polls have been killed about
germans wasn't it
you've heard of the
fingerprint of the united states cannot
firm and openly
cardio virtual stalin review monroe
sentiment that our country
rising tide will you know more about our
government that reading that put the
correct in that way
it wouldn't
created an underground movement of boat
but it would create an underground
movement in people's minds
lindsay
people overseas and although it's
probably for carmen
thing we've posted right
uh... general
an american corey
remembered penalty lasted for ten
always admired approved the great
fighters
and your life and you expect to return
to problems there
their savings
refund van crossed the big government
live
two three four
do you expect a manhunt goes down about
it
and what you think will happen then
confirm that but i think
papa doc
companies
unified
the queen's themselves
it's quite infrequent
with the attached between
its economy for forty
i don't think some sequel changes in the
house
then a general as our audience's
understood you sir
you would like the polls in america
understand that bolen has been through
many troubles before
and if you think that one day when the
free again thank you very much for being
with us
the coreldraw
for this edition of the laundry in front
of scope flaws
mister mack eastland
and that mister william bradford purely
our distinguished guests for study which
come up
better known as the frame the general
borough
leader of the folders on the ground in
world war two
lackluster approach football season is
in full swing
and put the brokaw report came from more
than a hundred leading product inventory
our prime time on june
the world's most al-kidwa before
yes the game for princeton proper
dartmouth california cryptogram aman
georgia tech convert mall are all crime
primary market
all professional game theory
all officials of the national football
league
the few judges the referees and the
observers used on do you want to be
exclusively for official driving
the reason
accurately enough of an empty claimed
but accuracy which has been demonstrated
time after time adhere after a year in
the competitive accuracy trials at the
great government observatory
yes for beauty program directors free
for the promise of a long and useful
life
throughout the world no other name on a
watch
means so much as laundry
premium product of the long gene with no
up front
thanks eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest debt
this is pragmatic and
inviting you to join up every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time far
alone being pumped up
a television journal of the important
because of the aisle
broadcast on behalf of loading the
world's most on edline
and what nor distinguished companion for
the world on a daunting
sold and service from coast to go
by more than four thousand leading
killer
who proudly display the emblem
agents they fall on jane but